[Music]
in ultimate pet owner news mm-hmm
admitted by I named my geography project
after Joe Mallya Wow you can now own a
zoo for $350,000 and it comes with the
animals oh that movie I don't think so
Mongoose way does it oh I want to do
that I found an exotic animal would be a
couple hundred thousand alone you like
that - $350,000 for your personal
aquarium the whole zoo you with the
animal who I was I only thinking of
dolphins dancing a dude I'd rather spend
transferred two grand on a bitchin home
entertainment dear system that inflate
planet Earth on high [ __ ] [ __ ] you
got that much I think you want to see it
around the craziest um you ever seen
like a theater room would cost that much
like even a dull one with an aquarium
bar would I support your dreams because
I want to come over a while before
community intervals during a fifty
thousand dollars I'm thinking really see
we could do it I [ __ ] scream [ __ ]
Dolby Surround down we can stretch that
dollar out 350,000 Eugene yeah 30
speakers in there so do the math oh five
it's all wrong I could trust me I can
spend three infinities now it's down
through feed bed you've got a bad deal
no I go over to get like the dopest like
freakin like you know now I'm bad Yelp
reject your guy I am like what's the
Chris Nolan one I don't know I get one
of those freaking projectors but is
making no no no I max dude I'm at Oh
70-something I would do that [ __ ] with
the whole wall mm-hmm thing you need to
chose like a whole new room huh that's
where the money's going
whatever he's not in charge of the money
why is a great idea 50 G's on a theory
she'll say later I think exactly that's
exactly she'll be the one I enjoyed
earlier yeah girl boys dude I know it's
a dangerous job I know that's the
opposite for us I always ordered the
better meal at the restaurant and then
he always eats off my meal
Hindus change orders the better food too
and a better tomorrow that I find the
better
every time yeah and sometimes he
criticized me while I'm ordering it and
then he likes it better
always they know how to order I don't
know girls they just pick the yummy
stuff not me you'll [ __ ] the zoo story
let's just talk about [ __ ] okay I got a
question - what kind of animals are
there because I don't want the shitty
car it's a cat and a dog I'm going out
[ __ ] zoo yeah every Mizzou's it's
kind of like a pony and on your pads a
pony on its a petting zoo it was like
some [ __ ] bathroom Craigslist on the
gray mud on Craigslist I want to see
some engagement species in there you can
actually I will tell you the animals
it's in albino zebra so you see monkeys
oh I like monkeys some lonely it says
it's a ten acre well-maintained USDA
complaint zoo jy USDA I mean making them
for food and shelter out of it is delish
USD hey wait United States drug at
notice what is your department
agriculture department yeah so that's
farming [ __ ] and food consumption right
and why is there why is it a zoo stuff I
don't know
okay continue so this is USDA we need to
feed them like they're they're certified
USDA prime monkeys and then when you see
certain monkeys like oh that monkeys
[ __ ] he's not used to you this is
the choice of monkeys choice time choice
collection he's not Prime salon he's
organic yeah it could be news turnkey
operation with over 90 happy and healthy
class 1 2 & 3 animals including white
tiger Bengal tiger leopard lion
what does monkey bobcats baboons wolves
otters black bear fennec foxes sloth
lemurs llamas and more calm down
experienced professional zookeepers
for operational buildings including 600
square feet entrance slash gift shop
with inventories and stuff a posh
machine 600 square foot commissary with
refrigerators freezers storage building
barns and additional outbuildings
grounds that's pretty sick like a me
until I can't even buy half of a house
of my neighborhood for that you can't
even get a house in the ghetto here yeah
started as a story and it ended as a
business opportunity yep I think we can
all agree yeah
yeah I'll go 5050 let's do it you can't
even buy 10 acres of grass I'll go 50
area cheap as we all pitch in 50 we can
get this oh [ __ ] see that's all right
then we've got to do like the movie with
a great movie and then we could all work
there and vlog there yeah cause we'll be
way better we do friends have the exact
same content I hope nobody hate Hilary
cakes in France uh no it's not the same
content it's different perspective and
we all have our own habitat that we made
first oh yeah you guys will be like a
jungle I could be like a safari
someone's like the Iceland yeah you're
like the shitty safaris I don't have
[ __ ] losers you get the meerkat you
know so they're also saying that there's
approximately half of acreage that's
undeveloped that is perfect for new
expansion and other recreational music
or we build our habits had even a home
site birthing it also includes the
tractor golf cart and maintenance but
but what kind of deal is it haunted
where is this right there's racist
people right next for role in it it's
like on Indian burial ground like
Appomattox [ __ ] burial ground so
there's a crack house next door that's
why they got to get rid of the property
this gang violence it's in the middle of
the game Sheena animal oh by the way bad
news it also has a liquor license I'm
like what's wrong with this place
I don't mean like it's perfect what yeah
this place is in Florida oh so they're
saying that it used to be like a
roadside attraction but then that's when
you can see the animals from the freeway
like that that's how they described a
roadside attraction like a drive-thru
[ __ ] yeah you just like they have
those really tries to zoo yeah they have
those like the San Diego Zoo does that
were like the wildlife safari thing well
right I think well you they put not
you're nothing you're like sitting there
in your Honda Accord like you know I
mean like you're on like the zoo zoo me
for something I am for whatever yes I am
like in the commercials when I was a kid
they made it look like you like we're
all in the road with in your car and
then you get but I think they were just
exaggerating it well I think they do
those
rides at the zoo they have like certain
parties that take you out to the lake in
the Wild Animal Park insane remember
like that's very talked about well in
the China there's a China zoo where they
let you drive through and then someone
got out of the car and the lion came and
[ __ ] them up yeah I didn't know wildlife
preserves though there's only somewhere
where I got out of card and I [ __ ] them
up it's always a guy the problem is
people is a woman looking in the Tanner
case if you forgot or does China yes
Chinese yeah yeah Tiger training so why
are they selling it it's not making
money so why would they want to sell
something that doesn't make any money
the reason why they're selling it is
because they're saying that now they've
rehabilitated all the animals that have
been there and so now they're saying
that it's time for them to focus on
rehabilitating other animals excuses
excuses
as a business owner I already know that
when you trying to get rid of some [ __ ]
you always have another excuse we're
moving out of time right you know we're
just trying something different with
life because even if you wanted to try
something new you could still sell it
for a way more yep I'm here this what
could be you guys and I'm I'm in and by
the way I have a great pitch for this
okay I think the entire zoo this is our
hook is you got to have some kind of
gimmick something get people in the
doors right so I'm thinking we put all
the animals in closed humanoid down I
already like that no because that's my
favorite yep monkeys in suits overall
and yeah George exhibit and they're the
janitor yeah monkey monkey janitors they
team up like they ride the elephant no
elephant comes with a mop and bucket
does that and he climbs down the trunk
and he's like scrubbing the windows
Cinderella yeah we could even see MIT
from the countries that they're from
like elephants would have like you know
like it shouldn't look like a gypsy or
some [ __ ] so I think they're wait I need
more from time at which is Dumbo Khan
yeah
there were so much gonna be cool like a
Latin team yeah exactly yeah like
Arabian Nights yeah I like this I like
this would be a black
yeah the monkeys have Spears and stuff
okay obviously business class monkeys
like they got briefcases Brit with the
watch watches I love that maybe
centuries out from but a cigarette on a
monster a repeated by the country
they're from what country is that one
key for all monkeys that pretty much
been American I don't have you know that
I watch they're from everywhere they're
modern the monkey from North Korea that
smokes cigarettes and they became an
attraction North Korean monkey smoke
yeah and the trainer taught him that so
he smokes a pack a day that was the
stressed out yeah he's just like this
and then pants for the cigarette because
he's an attraction that is an attraction
so all the zookeepers are just like no
no well he's not inhaling but he looks
like he's like would like he's like
chase do you like this let him do it
he's addicted he likes it I say let him
do what he wants for business so they
say that they are looking for someone
that has a passion for the welfare of
the animals in the zoo so they want
someone that will actually provide the
financial means to be able to keep the
zoo on the upward trend
III think will do a good job I mean like
they need clothes I'll do it and they
need to be bought more mmmm like I feel
like elephants are not logged enough and
that's whether we need to tell them
elephant story dude what if we need
every room every every exhibit where
they're at like look like a human
apartment oh look at that calm water
walk it through their human [ __ ] if you
like narrate what the animals are saying
yeah become the voices yeah what animal
lover I don't know I'm just listening to
just then speak there towards
imagination
yeah you see the vision no I can't go
fantasy I would never do that
why cuz you're cool to animals no why
because you know what animals really
want right you know what they're yeah
I'm an animal whisperer what he doesn't
know is your strategy to bring us to
resent you got out of Fame which is
what's next level yeah what I'm going to
do to get people in the bikini knowing
what this idea was this was just girls
in bikinis just servicing everything
behind bars like the tickets they're the
ones
Auto Opera is coming into my
only friendlies ooh uh playing exhibits
they're like in they have a bikini girl
exhibit zookeepers are what a bikini
yeah girl you rather exploit women than
animals no everyone has an option that's
pretty [ __ ] good it's like the
Hooters of Zeus I'm not gonna lie it is
pretty kind of cool and just like that
BAM
billion-dollar company you know my idea
for my part of the zoo is so I get a
moat like an island I get to make an
island and it's a kitten's island
there's a lot of kittens on how do you
keep them young how do you get people
for me to know and you to find out you
got a boat people after your kid
Madeline - well Sato
if they can't make the journey then they
can't enjoy the fruits of the labor of
making the journey sounds pretty fun
kids only going to be a kid for like a
month or bill but I'll make more kittens
oh I'll have a puppy pool you could swim
in a pool a puppy yeah I guess I'm just
not seeing the vision because I just
don't know it's like kittens natural
habitat is not an island my happy place
isn't in my head is it if you dress them
up like Gilligan's Island yes they not
havin so we got to thank you that I like
that Gilligan's Island one of the kidney
Acula we're going to be billionaires
guys hope you guys enjoyed that episode
if you guys have any juicy little guts
of details and you guys want to submit
it well guess what you can cruise on
over to the description box below click
on the link submit the story and
hopefully we will pick it and talk about
it for more videos click right over here
[Music]